all right guys
bang-bang I've got the man here himself
John thank you so much for doing this
man
of course of course thank you it's an
honor I was excited all week to you jump
on here listen you are uh you're
basically like the architect of uh of
content on the internet you've been
doing this a while so for like the
couple of people who are watching this
who don't know who you are let's start
with just your background and kind of
what you did before shot studios yes so
we actually found missed shot studios 11
years ago so my life before shot studios
was a little irrelevant even though I
was in the content business but but shot
studios when we first started we were as
production studio in 2009 trying to take
talent that wasn't on to the Internet
and bringing them onto the internet and
going really after like mainstream
celebrity specifically athletes so Mike
Tyson Usain Bolt
Floyd Mayweather Chad Ochocinco
Christiano Ronaldo were like early guys
that we were bringing it onto YouTube
back then the social media and the
internet was really YouTube and Twitter
there was nothing else yet Facebook was
out but Facebook was private pages only
via private profiles so I think we were
a little early for our time because the
monetization and the money wasn't there
and the guys that I just named right now
are like used to bags of cash up front
for them to even like leave their front
door so the monetization was in there we
were just trying to build an online
audience which was a little too early
for her anyone to wrap their head around
so then we made a pivot to our business
we had a very talented team we had
amazing relationships with Hollywood and
that's when we moved to San Francisco
and we launched an app called the shots
app and we were trying to get into the
platform business we said all right so
if we're trying to help the platforms
but no one was really getting it let's
create a platform business which is what
we created was a social network which
which was pretty much snapchat stories
and Instagram stories before both of
them incorporated stories into the
platforms we were the first know
no liking no light counts no follower
number just post your day don't
overthink what you're posting and get on
with the day there's an option to delete
it after 24 hours or the post could stay
the user could just decide whether they
wanted a said you know however way they
had their settings so we did that but
you know what happened to us was really
snapchat incorporated the future and if
the feature and it kind of hurt us you
know we were you know sometimes we in
platforms take a future it sometimes not
all the time it helps that platform and
takes the person that was initially
initially the innovator out of business
most times it doesn't work when
platforms just copy features but in the
case of us have didn't work and it
really hurt us but during that time a
lot of content creators like early
content creators like you know what you
call your thought you know see now is
like influencers or whatever you want to
call them we still call them content
creators we're really emerging because
of the vine app so that's when we went
to plan a and instead of going after
mainstream celebrities we said let's get
these early you know these early early
stage content creators who really know
how to build an audience in their own as
with their own niche and and help build
a team around them a studio random which
is what shot studios is today got it and
so one of the things that you guys are
super well known for is your not what I
call kind of the dumb content creator
right you're very very smart and
intelligent using data to drive a lot of
the decisions that you do you guys were
pretty early in understanding that I
previously worked at Facebook on the
Facebook pages team and it always you
know shocked me how as we were there
building this growth team like there
wasn't that many people using the data
that was provided in the analytics to
actually inform the concept that they
created you guys pioneer that in many
ways like talked a little bit about like
what was the original impetus for
focusing on the data and trying to use
that to actually inform the decisions
you get for making the consecration side
yeah well you know when you talk about
partnering up with an info
creator there's there's there's
thousands maybe tens of thousands so we
had you know we wanted to identify
people in two ways one is what is a
cultural fit for our company and is
there a real business to be made around
this creator and that's where the data
came in we would you know we have
internal tools that we have built
because the one thing is when we had our
engineers with the shots app we were
able to bring these in the engineering
team to also pivot what they were
developing into more back-end stuff and
we have access to a lot of different API
some are open some aren't open and we
are able to you know just build our own
internal saw core to see all right who
is really driving watch time who can
retain an audience who is growing in
markets that we could use growth in so
we're not lopsided with just a u.s.
audience and we could tap into some of
these other emerging internet markets
such as Brazil Mexico India some
different parts of Asia so you know but
that all you know that the the platform
share some data but not a ton they share
what's you know how you got here so far
but they don't really share where can
you go and that's where we built is you
know where could we go with this person
where can we go with this you know if
you have 22 million followers on a
specific platform what does that mean
what else can we do how do we go from 22
million or 50 million yeah and so
there's obviously a ton of attention
right now on content creators
influencers right that there's kind of
two buckets I'll call it there's one
that is like more I think generalized is
like the Instagram influencer who just
they take photos they get paid every
once in a while to do some advertising
but it's pretty much a single revenue
stream type content creation they've got
a single account what you guys really
have sorted to do it sounds like is
build entire businesses or ecosystems
around these content creators and
approach it much more as they are a
business Rae already mentioned
like when you're evaluating talent can
we build a business around them and so
maybe talk a little bit just kind of
philosophically how you guys think about
these content creator led businesses and
what that ecosystem kind of looks like
today when you're kind of designing them
yeah so we'd like to if you look at all
the different creators that we work with
and I believe there's 12 of them now
everyone is in their own lane everyone
you know one is a you know one could be
a comedian focused on a female audience
one's a comedian focus on the male
audience one has a very large Middle
Eastern Market which the Middle East
market is really growing you know in the
US and and throughout all of the Middle
East then in North Africa one has a very
large audience out of Mexico which is a
really a top-three market for Instagram
YouTube Spotify and I think it's Netflix
its fourth largest market one is a large
Brazilian following one is being
followed because of Education one's
being followed because of music so so
there's all these different verticals
within a creator and we're looking at
the different verticals that they create
content for and you know go you know
obviously we look at if the first thing
that I mentioned are they growing but
two is are they hitting a market where
we could actually cross promote other
creators so when there's a major
collaboration it really benefits
everybody and those are the things that
we look for those are the first two
things we work look for later we look
for look into you know and this is the
hardest part in the influence of world
is monetization you know we're how do
you create which I'm sure we'll get into
but you know that's that's you know
that's that's the third thing we look
for you not got those first two then you
could you could you know control your
own destiny when it comes to
monetization yeah and so once you know
kind of hey this is the right creator
they're growing in the right audiences
and we think that that audience has a
lot of runway right so you talked
earlier you know something's got 22
million followers you think you can get
them 250 million and and you kind of
understand the audience building site
how do you think about the monetization
like how has that evolved over time
given the various things at now
kind of are available on the Internet
yeah monetization is you know it's it's
um just quick ways to make money but
ours also you know as we're looking into
building long lasting careers we're
looking to building a lot of lasting
revenue flows and you know right now you
know we we you may get calls every day I
said we're gonna have two offers already
this morning with just different offers
then like hey we want you know you know
we sell you have this much engagement on
the Instagram of this much engagement on
tick-tock we would love to pay to have
these posts those happen all the time
those happen to almost anybody anyone
who is on the internet could get those
deals especially for you you have a you
know your email address in your bio then
you know advertisers are just crawling
and looking for you that song that's the
easy one that's one I don't really we
pay I pay attention to you obviously but
I don't really have a whole team within
shots that handles that part what I look
forward to is how do we build businesses
how do we we have our own audience we I
look at a creator as a micro platform so
if your micro platform how do we build
businesses going back to the shots up we
never when we were looking at building
the shots app or when we had the shots
app you know we had over 10 million
users and you know it at one point over
6 million active users we never a
monetization was never meant to be you
know okay so when do we start putting
banner ads and sponsored videos and you
know all these different things inside
the app that everyone else does how do
we you know we were looking for shots
app and we're not doing that with shot
studios is how do we build our own
businesses how do we happy we get into
merchandising businesses how do we get
into beauty how do we get to food and
beverage you know how do we get into
other consumer goods products whether
it's a toy a dog backpacks but how do we
do this without one-offs
you know someone coming in and giving
you a couple hundred thousand dollars
for a few posts and bouncing how do we
actually own that how do we create our
own beats by dre
you know then those are the things that
we think of you know
how do we create our own vitaminwater
you know what 50 cent did with vitamin
water how do we create these products
for each one of our creators these are
the things we're working on so to me
this is the most interesting thing in
all of the internet right and the reason
being a couple years ago I started
thinking pretty deeply about this idea
of like audience is the new currency and
I think a lot of people use that as like
oh some advertisers are gonna come pay
me money and then I can simply you know
post or do whatever and I get that cash
but what you're talking about there's a
very well-known author who one time said
to me if somebody's willing to pay me to
reach my audience that means that that
audience is more valuable to me than it
is to them right basically I can sell my
own things through all this kind of
stuff and it started to walk me through
like look looking for very specific
types of products that were high margin
that he could sell through that he knew
that there was a wide enough kind of
interest in his audience like he was
very very smart about it and it sounds
like you guys are thinking through a lot
of that same stuff has it been driven at
all or do you see coral corollary kind
of analysis to what whether its Kylie
Jenner Kanye West like a number of these
people have done where they already had
built-in audiences and then they went
and created a product it feels like
that's a much more repeatable
sustainable business model given that
you retain ownership of that audience
right so you can build multiple products
and multiple companies and keep kind of
bringing them more and more things over
time rather than just an advertiser
comes one time you advertise once and
then they're gone like the company piece
seems more sustainable and repeatable
right of course of course yeah you
control it I mean especially in the
influencer turn content creator business
is advertisers are afraid they're afraid
you know and and their expectations are
so high because people are comparing
YouTube to television they're saying
okay well you know you've spent this
much money on that TV show that had two
million views well I'm getting 10
million views you know so I'm five times
more and you know and and you know
there's always the tug-of-war between
the creator and the advertiser and then
advertiser eventually says okay someone
at the office says you know you might be
right let's give it a shot and then the
conversions not the same because people
on the Internet just don't want to see
ads they don't have to see ads on
television you know you're you're kind
of stuck you're forced you know unless
you know you previously recorded and you
fast-forward to it through it but you
know or if you're it's a radio
you know station like you know you're
kind of a force unless you just switch
the station but on the internet business
is just like you know the conversion is
so much lower that's you know then the
advertiser says that that person was
wrong oh by the way look at this guy
he's now swearing in his content or he's
smoking weed or he did this or she did
that and and then you know didn't then
someone says hey why did you do that
that wasn't children-friendly you know
and then all this whole mess comes in
and the advertiser pulls out and we
never hear from them again
so and and I don't blame the advertiser
right it is the wild wild west on the
internet right now people are just you
know I mean the more yourself the better
your content your better your channel is
going to grow but the more yourself the
more you know you're less political your
lest phony so you know it's not what the
apertures are advertisers want to see
they want to see the picture-perfect
version of you so so an advert I said
okay this is not for us so then where
does that leave you know when you went
back bragging about getting ten million
views how are you going to now make
money you know you're just gonna brag
about the 10 million views and live at
home or live on your buddy's couch you
know so that's that's when you know then
you got to go and you got to create your
own t-shirt and create a culture and a
following and not a following to number
following somebody that really cares
about you and Bill and and have them
join this culture how them join dis
click or squad whatever you want to call
it and buy a product and now that money
goes directly to you
you know Shopify since daily deposits
yeah I mean so you're literally making
money every single day when you wake up
which data goes into determining what
plot for companies to build versus it's
like the creators intuition and just
personal interest I think so you know
it's like creating a video you know
you're gonna some
times were even guilty of this will
create a video that we just wanted to do
and it just doesn't register with the
audience and we will just keep doing it
and doing it and doing it until it's
something that we're passionate about
and then the audience like and then you
see the views and engagement go up I
think a product a product that a creator
really wants to get behind it's kind of
going to have to be the same thing you
know you could take advice from people
you could you know right like right now
CIA has CIA labs where like they really
take I haven't used it but I've heard
about it and I know the people behind it
they're very smart people so you know
they're they're going in and they're you
know they're looking at like your
audience on across everywhere you are on
the internet and pitching creators like
we think your audience is gonna like you
know George pickles and you know and you
know seltzer water you know whatever it
is you know like you know I I think that
could work but at the end of the day it
really depends on what the audience
wants you know if you're a comedian with
the very low fault you're a comedian
with a very young following then maybe
you know custom suits is not your thing
you know so you just have to kind of
really understand your audience no
different than when you're making the
video you're making the music is what
does your audience one and the product
has to be the same thing as shots right
now we're trying trying to treat
products like a creator you know and we
want to turn products into creators and
that's why you know I mean I'm a big fan
of this liquid death you know I mean
like this is content it is you know
people laughed they you know they you
know they asked questions I had a call
with their team last week about content
ideas and you know it's like this is
this is content this draws your
attention you know is like what is that
you want to know more I've read
everything on this can all the labels
and everything just to get a kick out of
it and you know it's all standard stuff
that they have legal stuff in your foot
but even like the fonts I'm looking at
it you know I mean it's just I got my
attention
and that's
turning a product into a content creator
and and if a creator could get behind
one of these and do that with the
product and you have these two things is
just it's that much more explosive and
you see a lot of youtubers do that with
merch right now the best merch that
sells right now is March built around
their content and their fandoms versus
like a picture of their face with their
name on it you know those don't really
convert well people don't really want to
buy your name on a t-shirt they want to
buy something cool that fun that you
made that it says that has been
incorporate into your content so then
they're part of the following a part of
the squad they're part of the you know
the the audience that usability
yeah and how much of this is now being
empowered by the stripes of the world
the Shopify's you know all of these kind
of infrastructure companies that have
made it dead simple for creators to
actually do this themselves or is it
even if those companies didn't exist
this was already a trend that kind of
people were moving towards because you
saw it happening where people weren't
using Shopify stripe and things like
that yeah I don't think any of this is
easily said to do if there was no
Shopify you know it's not you know it
wouldn't be something I was like just
get up and do it you know because when
you right now when I tell you you and
you and you know your audience and
whoever's listening or even our creators
is you don't have to worry about how to
do this you just have to do to worry
about what to do and what to sell you
don't worry about how how how's the
Shopify has made it so damn easy that
it's not even like like when we launched
the little shop calm which is our merch
site like Shopify and building properly
Shopify was like action item number
eight on our like 20 thing to do list
you know it wasn't a before I used to be
like I build a web site figure this out
and have analytics and you know figure
out emails and all this but now it's
like all right you just it's like saying
create an Instagram account for the
brand it's just like that's not an
important thing more important thing is
what to sell right now the quality of it
you know right now that's the the top
three priorities to us with little shop
in any of our consumer goods products is
you know build something that the
audience loves make sure it's of quality
and have great customer service like
like Zappos level customer service yeah
I mean so the person comes back you know
you did all this work to get them to go
to the website and purchase and put in a
credit card and you want them to come
back and those things ever what's makes
it important and Shopify has made it a
world where creators could we'll focus
on those three things and not worry
about how do I build a website who do I
call outsourced overseas you know I mean
like you don't have to worry I spent
$50,000 on this thing that you know if
they're worried about that you know
because that's what his website would
cost at the little Shopify when you're
talking about all the back and stuff
that they provide all the analytics
everything you know I mean like it's not
just a front-end thing that's the
backend thing that makes it
Shopify what it is it's an absolutely
incredible company and I think you
nailed it in the sense of like it's
almost a foregone thought at this point
right people just oh of course I'm gonna
have a Shopify you guys are obviously
creating content for all kinds of
different platforms but everything kind
of starts and ends with YouTube and then
you kind of go to these other platforms
YouTube's been around a long time it's
not just got a massive audience right it
I think of it even is like the second
largest search engine in the world but
why do you guys spend so much time on
that platform compared to you know
whether it's a new shiny platform that's
come up or other ones that are that are
even larger in some cases um a few
reasons and they're all pretty much
equally important and I would tell you
for one of them one of the reasons is
there's no when you're in the video
content business there's no limits on
what you could create on YouTube you can
make it vertical you can make it wide
you can make it 20 seconds you can make
it 20 minutes or two hours you know it's
available you know the product itself is
available everywhere all mobile devices
desktop
all Smart TVs you know Apple TV Roku
chromecast you know if I stick
everything so it's available everywhere
that products great that's that's one of
the reasons another one of the reasons
is um to me you know just being around
this for so long I'm just paying
attention to the Internet for so long
it's the safest place for our content
you know one thing Google does not do is
it just does not mess things up they you
know yeah they've had some flops when
they've tried to launch things from
start Google Plus wave I'm sure there
was a few other ones that we just don't
remember but we laughed at them when
they do try to do it but once a product
is up and going they don't mess it up
yeah I mean they did not mess up the
Google search they did not mess up Gmail
they did not mess up maps you know I
mean like they you know these are all
products that you know once it's there
they don't mess it up they don't make
sudden product changes because someone
got fired or someone came in and you
know came from here and convince someone
at this worse they don't do that so to
us like it's a safe place then another
part is monetization you know the fact
that there's monetization and and very
good money you know you know I'll never
get into how much money our creators
make is that's really private to do them
and they don't really like talking about
it that's why you never see us on the
Forbes list they think it ruins the
integrity of the content which I agree
but it's no secret when you go and see
what some of these top YouTube made
creators make they make that you know
I've been to YouTube creators houses
that you know that are ten million
dollars you know in Calabasas and they
made it and they dyno the money that's
being made there so the monetization and
the better you do and the you know the
better you do and the less of an [ __ ]
you are on the line and milotic us on
here of course yeah once I said ask the
line me like if you curse on a you know
piece of content which is what I did so
I hope I didn't ruin your monetization
but but
podcasts are different as the beauty of
podcasts you just now you could really
be yourself but but as long as you do
you know you can make a really good
living off youtube now is it safe to be
dependent on advertisers no but at least
it helps you build that foundation so
you could go back to what we talked
about with Shopify and all these other
consumer good products and you can build
the products yourself in and fund your
projects yourself and not be dependent
on advertiser you know whatever one two
three to come in so that's another
reason and then and then and then one
other part that's really important to us
and I always talk about this is the
people that work at YouTube are some of
the greatest people in the world they're
the greatest people I work with they're
the people that when they call I'm not
rolling my eyes say uh you know because
I get a lot of phone calls lawyers
accountants businesspeople other
managers you know other producers all
this stuff will call me and I'm just
saying oh man I don't want deal this but
when something from YouTube cause I'm
like they're just I don't know the
culture how they created this culture
they're what Robert Kensal has done to
create this culture where everybody is
happy everybody is honest
everybody is open-minded that we work
with there and that like that like
drives us keeps you know so we don't
have to worry about that part we know
that the people that are behind the
platform that we're creating on our good
people so we're just not a fair thinking
like man you know and I've been in this
industry before in the past I you know
I'm in business here but I can't wait
though they I'm not here you know and
that's never really a thought a lot of
the platforms are really good people
with YouTube who we've had this
relationship with so long just that's
that itself and that's what I'm saying
all these things together are equally as
important for us to say I were a YouTube
first company and everything else we're
gonna build we're gonna build around
this because it's important to be
everywhere you can't be lopsided to just
YouTube you gotta be everywhere you know
I mean someone's you know addicted to
tick tock today and it's gonna spend
hours on tick tock I can't miss that
person just because their habit
because they woke up this morning and
got a link text to them to go about a
funny tick-tock and then they just got
warped into this world of I'm just gonna
spend the day on tick-tock you know I
mean I can't lose that person because of
that I can't control where they're gonna
be so it's important to be everywhere
but at the end of day YouTube is you
know the to us to our company in the
most important there's a reason why
they're so big and they've been around
so long right doing something right how
do you guys think about tick-tock and
kwibi is another kind of newer video
platform what about those two um well
quit bi
we never really got on I just really
wasn't sure I'm not sure about it
currently you know so it's just you know
we'll just wait to see what happens and
as they build their audience you know
we'll just take a look and if they have
an audience and it resonates with our
audience and we could actually you know
get a jump start with their existing
audience and maybe move our audience
there we'll take a look but we haven't
gotten there yet with kwibi and that's
how I felt about the tick-tock one year
ago this time and then about August
September of last year s all right
there's an audience here and and our
audience does like tick-tock by us just
don't you know some R&D work and and
then we launched our tick-tock accounts
I think it was the last week of August
last year so it was that 10 months ago
and nothing we have on your like 15
channels and over 100 million followers
on tick-tock in just 10 months yeah like
we're and we have you know we have an
account of 16 million won with 14 - or
12 yeah we have it we have a very large
following on tick-tock and yeah it's a
trip what do you attribute that growth I
mean that that's astronomical growth for
any platform but even for tick-tock
that's super impressive like why is that
happening except because you guys are
better than others are creating content
is it's the content creators you have
like what is the difference for you guys
to have that type of success
I think it's I think it's really us
understanding the audience you know us
understanding spending some time sitting
back and paying attention for a little
while who the tic-tock audience is it
then on you know understanding our
audience and then doing some testing and
going back to our development team and
just having them to kind of take a look
at you know does us it does us posting
on tik-tok help us in other places in
the answer's yes
specifically on Instagram it really
helps us with our Instagram emails and
our Instagram the growth houses with our
YouTube growth so does that help and the
team came back and said yeah we said all
right cool then that's when we put the
foot down on the gas and said let's just
go bid it and explain that more when you
say tick-tock helps you grow Instagram
and Instagram helps you grow YouTube how
are those connected well
they discover you because it's a whole
different world can you hear me okay
okay when it's a whole different world
of people on tick-tock but it's a world
that understands us so we're getting a
lot of eyeballs on people who've never
seen us anywhere else and are coming to
us you know finding us on tick-tock and
seeing that oh I like this guy I like
his content or her content or that her
as a person or whatever it is I want
more well I don't want to wait til
tomorrow till they post again works are
they and and then tick tock has that
future where you could click on
someone's Instagram profile and it deep
links you to the Instagram app oh great
they're posting something completely
different different side this person I
knew I liked this person glad I did this
who is this person let me read more the
link and bio youtube link oh wow
youtube video this can be long oh my god
i really love this person youtube link
you know I think this video is great I
want to subscribe turn on notifications
and and now you've got this person who
start found you on site off
it's got deep
to Instagram click the link in Baia
almost all our links and BIOS are
YouTube videos and and came to YouTube
and now we got a you know on three
different platforms yeah and then it
feels like you guys have done a great
job kind of doing this for video I know
that another area you guys are focused
on moving forward is podcast you've
booked on a podcast studio you're gonna
go kind of build that it's one of the
pillars of the business what's the
intrigue or fascination with audio and
in the whole podcast world yeah so that
um that world that I just told you about
let's just say like that's kind of the
cycle let me find you on tick-tock the
hottest app out right now by far then
let me see more about you on Instagram
then let me go see even more and watch
you more on YouTube and subscribe we
don't want to lose them there you know
but you've already showed them a short
video probably something funny in 15
seconds show them a bunch of photos you
show them a longer video what what else
you really want to learn about this
person you really want to know now that
you're really you know fascinated with
this person
well here their brain yeah subscribe now
go to wherever Spotify wherever and now
here you know here's a clip on youtube
go to listen to this person on Spotify
Apple wherever you'd listen to podcasts
and here's a one hour of this person raw
and on cut you know so it's kind of goes
to that cycle and while you're there you
know don't buy their t-shirt you can't
really be in this person's world you
know you're in their brain you see what
they like you see though the interests
are you're part of their squad now with
your piece your merger your your shirt
your hoodie your hat
and you know a mega part of this
person's life you know you got a friend
yeah and I guess how do you think about
the different types of content on these
platforms so video obviously is a very
specific medium right and so you can
change the types of content that you
post on a tick-tock on YouTube on this
like there's different lengths there's
different types of content that does
well in each of those audio is a whole
different ballgame right maybe they can
take it you know podcasts and you do a
video and puts it on youtube or
something like that but for the audio
only platforms how do you think about a
different type of content meaning like
what is the creators who are really good
at video and on these kind of more
traditional platforms what are they
thinking about creating in the audio
medium
yeah I think in the audio world and you
know I have to throw out this disclaimer
that I'm still learning and our team is
still learning and we're hiring people
to run your audio side that have more
experience than I do or than my brother
who's my who's the co-founder of the
company do and we've hired some really
great people we have a we have an
amazing partnership with Spotify that
was announced earlier this year with the
podcast that we're doing with Lily pons
and Spotify has been beyond helpful as
well to helping us learn but the one
thing I've got to say and the reason why
I even agreed to come on your podcast is
people who your audience is tuning in
right now to learn something and you
know I could come in and talk about all
the cool thing I have the cool things
I've done and all the cool people I know
and all the great life that I have
but the podcast audience is really tuned
in right now to learn something when you
are when you interviewed Alex from
BuzzFeed or formerly a bus remove big
technology sugarman Keshava killer
Lorenz you know these are all former
episodes of your podcast that I listen
to and I didn't listen to you to know
about them they're all three of them or
actually my friends I talk to them all
the time
I know what they're up to you know I
mean I know Taylor's moving out of her
apartment in New York City and going to
another place yeah I mean like yeah I
mean like I know alex is starting up
those don't they but I learned something
from each one of those podcasts I
learned you know I learned so much from
all three of them completely different
things to three different people three
different businesses but they are you
know they they got my attention because
they spark my interest and that's what
we've got to learn with our audience is
what do they want to learn you know are
we gonna come and lay that it's gonna
talk about
how great her birthday party and Miami's
been and how much fun she's having or
she's gonna actually like someone gonna
walk away and look and say wow I did not
know that that was really interesting
because that's when they go talk you
know these are all like conversation
icebreakers that's when they go talk I
do it all the time I learn something
from a podcast and I'll go back to my
best friend was my fiancee and I just
you know I'll say something and she's
like how do you know that I was like I
listen to his podcast you know and I
like and I think that's what people
really want at a podcast and that's what
we're learning right now and that's what
we're that's why we're building this
it's a whole different side of us that
no one's been able to get anywhere else
that they're gonna get with the podcast
video that we're building that's awesome
and I think you're right in the sense of
because it's usually longer form and
it's audio there's definitely this
learning element what I've been thinking
a lot about and I don't have the answer
to is how interchangeable audio content
is so for example I know a lot of people
a couple years ago with like the rise of
audible and things would say hey look I
don't really read books as much I
actually listened to them so started to
get really big into audiobooks it feels
like now podcasts and audiobooks in some
way compete with each other for time
because both of them are learning but
it's not you know once a book that's
kind of very well thought out the other
is either an individual kind of you know
sharing content one-to-one or they're
interviewing somebody right it just
feels like it's a kind of an updated
book or audiobook to some degree in some
weird way how do you think about the
creators you guys have a lot of
comedians are kind of comedy focused
content how do they teach or do
education being kind of more of the the
humor side of consecration yes so you
know I kind of find a different word in
education what I'm going to call my
education you're not gonna like tune in
and you're not gonna learn from Leila's
podcast you know Howie Tesla is built
you know like that's not the kind of
education you know you're gonna learn
something else you might teach
somebody she might teach somebody that
you know her audience right because cuz
it would be awesome to this for me or
maybe even you to listen to a podcast
that talks about how attesa it really is
built where do they get the materials
from where you know what kind of metals
are they using were they mined you know
all the stuff would be really
interesting to me but not lately is
oddness lately as audience might want to
learn what are the best time to post on
tick-tock yeah to go viral you know what
are the pull of s times to post on
Instagram should I post videos or share
those photos on Instagram what should a
racially you know and though that's her
audience and those are things that we're
learning for each one of the pockets
that were launching with each one of the
creators is what does each person's
audience want to learn in the case of
rudy mancuso when he gets around doing
our podcast he might talk about how to
direct a youtube video or in that and
then how to direct a YouTube video
that's 40 minutes long how to direct a
YouTube video that's one hours long then
how to get off YouTube and direct a film
that's an hour and a half that I could
go somewhere outside of YouTube yeah
people want to learn those things
especially in the world now with sadly I
know of almost over 50 million
unemployed Americans people are going to
look to the internet say okay I don't
think my restaurants gonna open up
anytime soon my guest
a couple mouths to feed I keep hearing
about youtubers making all this money I
feel like I'm interesting I've never
seen anyone do anything that's in that
my brain is generating to to me how do I
start where do I start where do I you
know what do I do
what what cameras are these guys using
what I mean I can imagine a podcast I
could break all that down for you and
you know you don't have to worry about
you know whenever it's time to go back
to work and trying to compete with 50
million other people to get a job back
well if you control your own destiny
where do you start and I think you know
if if someone really could create a
podcast like that or anybody maybe one
of your listeners could create a podcast
like that they've got something there
and I think those are the things that
make podcast so beautiful is that now
you have all different verticals of
podcasts you have talk shows yeah you
know the the crime stuff you know you
have these other ones but to me you know
that's what we want to do we want to
take the things that we have learned
over the years and share that with scare
them with the world
yeah and so how do you think about
alcohol kind of the the maturation or
the rise of a content creator right so
many of the content creators you work
with start out online for example then
they've kind of moved over to YouTube
they've both these big followings tic
toc comes out they've been following
there we've talked a lot about kind of
how you monetize that but there's also
seems at least from the outsider view
looking in certain inflection points
from the the popularity or the audience
right so things like getting a Netflix
show or getting on to traditional
television or those things actually in
the eyes the Creator in the eyes of you
guys seen as kind of further along in
the maturation and popularity of a
creator or is that more of just the
external folks think that getting on
television or getting a Netflix show is
a big deal but actually the creators
that they're not even really worried
about the suffer or aspire to do that it
really depends on the creator's interest
and what they want to do whether it's
what their heart wants to do or what
their talent allows them to do it really
depends you know we look at our company
you know it's centered in the middle is
YouTube and then outside of YouTube we
have all these other ancillary
businesses that Schatz is building and
they're all like really based around
what we feel like the world needs you
know one part is music one compartes
podcasts one parts merchandise one parts
of consumer goods product right one part
is other social networks you know we
have all these different ancillary
businesses that are built around YouTube
and I'm sorry there's a six part so it's
really six and there's television and
film
and it really depends from what the
creator wants to do we had to pour that
Orient's one of them's been on a little
bit on hold but it really depends on
what the creator wants to do you know
what we do is we help them build we help
all our creators build the YouTube
channels we build our own YouTube
channels we have our own completely
different original side that is really
one to have originals ourselves for the
company for ideas that you know we could
create an experiment and then share with
all our other twelve channels to help
evolve the channels as well this is also
that's something else always think about
is you know there is a time where
someone gets over somebody you know just
because they subscribed to you at 14
years old does that mean that they want
to watch you when there are 17 years old
just because they subscribe to you when
there are 18 years old does not mean
they want to watch what you're creating
at 21 years old people at age up so we
create all these other business these
are these other kind of content which we
call shots originals too to really
experiment other types of content so all
our channels together to start probably
so it really depends on where the
creator wants ago you know they might
have some other random idea but we have
all these different businesses within
shots that a creator could really do
whatever they want they want to get
become a musician we have a whole record
label that has songwriters producers
relationships with all platforms radio
stations obviously we have our own video
production company and shot studio so
they can make a music video everything
everything you know everything
everything if someone wants to become an
artist a podcast studio now with now as
I mentioned a team of producers that
have come from different very successful
podcasts that could help someone if they
have an idea of a podcast we could build
it yeah and so you sit in a very
interesting place I think because you've
got folks who started out unknown and
relatively small but have built
incredible careers and incredible
audiences in the tens of millions in
terms of consecration on the internet
you also are very close with people that
I would consider
more traditional celebrities right so
this is the Justin Bieber's to Floyd
Mayweather's and drop that entire a
group of people who really kind of got
popular not on the internet social media
platforms but because of the nature of
what they do they've got to be on those
platforms right so you see they've got
these massive followings how do you
think about the difference in approach
for somebody who's built their
popularity and celebrity on the
platforms versus somebody who built it
elsewhere and then kind of creates
content as a kind of a secondary piece
to what their career is actually you
know grown into well Floyd and Justin I
met both during phase one of our
business when we had the studio at first
with Floyd he always was a believer in
us creating these content around
different celebrities he including
himself which we launched his YouTube
channel many years ago maybe almost 10
years ago and and just then like I
remember my first time I met Justin the
first time I taught them about the
business was we were gonna build like a
cartoon studio and we were gonna create
cartoons with with with different
celebrities and then right around then
is when they both actually invested in
the company shortly after they invested
we realized that this phase is not
working right now and then we launched
the app which they were okay you know
they were perfectly fine with the pivot
and they actually said well we actually
maybe liked this idea more the app
sounds great and of product they saw the
product and they loved the product the
product was flawless at the time like it
was next-level like the team they're up
since no on San Francisco and I always
pay attention to know the things they're
building like the best out there some of
the apps major apps right now that most
people really love were built by the
team that actually created shots they've
moved on obviously not working with us
but you know and then and then the app
and then and then when I was trying to
go back to square face one I don't know
why I'm seeing phase like it's
coronavirus but it you know but it's a
you know but plan a you know
they you know they were all about it and
they were supportive and you know
they've just been real big supporters as
most investors and moral support with us
to creating to allowing us to create
what we do and that's why we have such a
great relationship with both of them I'm
gonna say I talked to both of them maybe
seven days a week you know Floyd
definitely I mean I said they usually
just different things he always has
ideas and we bounce off each other and
you know then he's asking about the
company and I'm gonna I've been up to
and you know how is the day and what's
tomorrow look like and whatnot you know
Justin does the same as well they know
Justin obviously Falls or social
accounts when we post something about a
specific project yeah he's always the
focus of cause I hey what is this about
you know what is house it's time and
everything else you know there's not you
know you sit as a teaser can I see the
full thing and all that some liberalism
incredible and been thinking Floyd
invested in the company in 2010 and just
invested in the company 2012 over 2013 I
don't remember and yeah it's been quite
some time they've been so supportive of
everything yeah that's awesome
and it feels also like a lot of the more
traditional celebrities whether they're
musicians artists athletes whatever
they've gotten much much smarter over
the years about how not only one they
can build the online audiences but to
also monetize them as well right and you
mentioned a couple earlier you know the
50 cent with the vitamin water and
things like that how do you think about
creators as investors rakes I think one
of the things that is already
interesting is like hey I can build
these companies or I can use my audience
another thing is I can take capital that
I have I can invest it into a startup a
company whatever and then I can help
them get to my audience right but I'm
doing it not as the majority owner just
as a minority owner like what is that
conversation been like if at all with
with creators it really I mean that all
really depends on the creator or the
celebrity and the brand you know it
doesn't always make sense but had
sometimes it does you know I think
Sharon was one that really understood
okay I've got this company whether it
was through his phone or when he worked
men
was like I've got this company and I'm
not the perfect person that can actually
help this company and you know he would
you know find out in Los Angeles I
remember those days like you would fly
down in Los Angeles and have meetings
with the right people that were great
for that brand for that product for that
company so he would always bring very
very smart entertainment money into the
startup and and I think a lot of people
have followed that path and a lot of
people have done it but some people
still do it wrong you know it just it
doesn't make sense you know a for a
let's say a youtuber who has a very
young audience that watches him or her
because they do pranks to invest in a
medical device company yeah I mean I I
mean like some time but it happens you
know sometimes you know the medical
device company gets excited because the
person has a lot of followers on YouTube
tik-tok Instagram and then this other
person is sold on like hey you know
you're 50 grand could become 10 million
dollars this is how you invest you could
be part of Silicon Valley and then this
is a forced relationship and it just
never really works and then the creator
gets over it because they posted about
it and no one we know they call it the
companies they had at dudes like I
didn't convert you know you're not the
right person and creators like well I am
what do you mean I'm not the right
person you know who I am I mean it
becomes this big weird thing and then
there's all this presentment built and
you know like and that thing that's one
thing that
shervin did a great job with and I know
there's a lot of firms are gonna create
job with it and I'm just not to go
through there but Sharon was always the
one I remember really like pushing hard
for companies that he had investment to
fly down to LA and meet with the perfect
partner yeah that's awesome and then how
do you in the in the creators that you
work with think about kind of the legacy
media right in terms of we're now seeing
specific reporters focusing on internet
culture at so Taylor Lorenz a New York
Times is obviously probably the leader
there but how do you guys thought about
that given that many of the craters are
able to build
large audiences and talk directly to
them via these other platforms like I
said even part of the strategy to
leverage the legacy media and some of
the the more kind of incumbent
publications yeah I mean yeah I think
you know people care they have a
audiences you know their audiences are
human beings you know every night
they're they're still reading the New
York Times or or Wall Street Journal or
Ad Age billboard to filter so that you
know they're they're reading these you
know and people care about them they
have audiences like obvious is bigger
than more more people that these these
publications are covering you just need
to know as a reporter who has that
audience and not the one-off not
audience know who's not not I'm gonna
write about this person now but they're
gonna fall off the face of earth in
three months or my story is really
irrelevant in three months and I think
that's where someone like Taylor has
nailed she knows who has the audience
who is coming on if they have gone
because she was wrong
Wyatt what happened to them yeah me show
no she doesn't said I go I messed up I
don't know what happened no no no this
person's self destructed because they
did this and they did that they did this
bonehead move and bah-bah-bah she really
does she's she's the best she is she
there's nobody like her you know and
I've got told her that I talked to her a
couple weeks ago and she probably
thought I was me trying to pitch a story
to her but I didn't wasn't even trying
to do that I just want to tell her how
awesome she is and what she's doing for
the internet culture right now it's
awesome there's gonna be copycats you
know I think maybe I don't know you've
got to have some you know some some of
these publications are so you know old
school thinking that I don't know if
they would you know hire someone like
Taylor who will spend some time with
tick tock errs and travel with tick tock
errs to see you know what is this you
know this this shift and culture you
know I think that the one publication
that does a great job and because it
really focused on this business is to
filter - filter commlite those guys
really get it and they're just I mean
they're every article on that site I'm
just like okay yeah alright I'm never
reading an article saying this isn't for
me or this is BS or
suck like they really saw as a reporter
Taylor is the best out there and as a
and there's a lot of other great ones I
just you know she's just stands out to
me as the that goat you know the
greatest of all time right now you know
I mean like she really is she's she's
and then and then to filter as a as an
actual site doesn't an incredible job
others are starting to copy them but
yeah and what a lot of questions I have
for you is as you think about creators
is kind of this platform or micro
platform right and then you've got the
products that you can really create as
content help me understand the balance
between what I'll call with more analog
or physical products so t-shirts you
know cosmetics whatever versus software
products so working with a creator
actually build up like a more scalable
technology company that thing is piped
through to their audience how do you
guys kind of think through physical
products versus software yet so um right
now you know our focus is physical
products it's something that you know
because of Shopify and how easy they've
made it weird
we're going down the route of getting
physical products that our audience
would what would like would enjoy would
come back would not feel ripped off
buying and that stuff focused now um
I've never thought of really virtual
products I mean I you know I had one of
the best apps in the world at one point
and you know it was like a little bit
like I still a bit heartbroken and what
happened so I've never really I get it
sometimes on like building another app
but it didn't you know I should be idea
down within you know a few hours of
thinking about the idea and I just said
you know don't be you know right now we
look at us because we create for all
platforms we look at like the platform's
as like you know as I use as an example
once and I actually got some weird
tweets about it saying bad example so
I'm gonna do it again
is um is you know we look at the
platforms as like you know if there's
like a big war because they're all at
war with each other we look at them as
like countries at war and we're
the ones building your armory you know
like we're just you know whatever your
needs are you need tanks we got tanks
you need missile lectures we have
misogyny f-14s we got f4 routines yeah I
mean we're the company I always forget
the company that uh yeah that builds all
these done and I think Texas but we want
to be there for the platform's you know
you get you have vertical video that
disappear in 24 hours we got a content
for that you know you have 15-second
videos we got that you know you have you
know even if we were to do something for
kwibi
you know which we haven't yet but you
know you want videos that look both you
know great vertically and horizontally
we could do that you know we could just
do anything you don't want audio you
want music and and so that's because of
that that's just like so fun and there's
such a need for that that we don't
really have we're not really looking to
build any software now now there are
software is that creators can team up
with and if we find the right company
will do that stalking a friend of mine
phased banks
he's from the part of the faze clan and
one of the greatest human beings in the
world we're just catching up yesterday
we just moved not too far from each
other and you know you just tell me how
you know how much money other their
their eSports crew and he was just tell
me about how much money they make off
like skins you know and a number was
crazy crazy like way more I'm just
thinking like oh and that's all profit
you know you don't have to buy the
product and build a fulfillment center
which is what we've done and you know
deal with shipping and deal with you
know all this you're just creating skins
like that it's just pure profitability
so if we get to that point where we can
partner up with someone that makes sense
and it makes sense to our audience will
definitely do that
yeah I love that you've been doing this
for a long time what's uh what's one or
two of the biggest lessons you've
learned over the last call a decade or
so in the content business on the
Internet
um always be evolving you can't be
comfortable you know an average creator
last career last three years you know
like I said you know eventually people
age up just like an average TV show last
three years you know I'm here you know
came of Thrones and these other ones
that a lot
but an average TV show lasts three years
an average graters last three years so
don't live to see if the sink is
shipping you have to jump just figure
out how to not sink and keep sailing you
know so you know that that's that's the
one thing I think you know when the ship
is sailing you know I feel like you know
they either you know you either drown
with it or you just jump off but I think
you know you got to always be evolving
there's so many things to do you know
like we just named all the different
things that we need and we really get
into snapchat or Twitter or you know I
mean you know some of these Chinese
platforms the other Chinese quadrant not
the tic TOCs but there's there there's
dozens of other ones in China you know I
mean we even talked about any of that we
haven't talked about what's the one that
reporters are using right now to write
their own articles in that medium but
there's a like a medium some stem so
yeah yeah then yeah I mean like these
are all places today you could like girl
audiences so keep just keep doing that
and don't be lopsided in one place yeah
I love that one of my favorite questions
to ask people now is what is the best
decision you've made in your career and
what is the worst decision you've made
in your career the best decision I've
made in my career has got to be building
this studio and a studio that is not a
that does not focus on one thing focus
on different thing because I'm someone
that does go to sleep with ideas and
dreams and new ideas and wakes up with
new ideas and you know to take away my
anxiety or this not take away things I
would take away anxiety before it's
built up is I just experimenting you
know as a creative many creative people
you know they they get their anxiety and
which could lead to other bad dark
things where there's depression and drug
use or anything like that is you just as
a creative person not let it sit and
your subconscious mind get it out and I
think that's one of the reason why we
build the studio like we can do almost
anything we record music record videos
or film videos
podcast is is that and it's really
helped me and you know not everything
have we created has worked we've done a
lot of things that haven't worked as
well
but at least I did it you know at least
I'm happy about it I don't regret
anything that I've ever created whether
it worked at didn't work we spent a lot
of money on certain children's
programming right before children's
programming took a hit on monetization I
don't regret it I loved it you know
anywhere now we're doing other
children's programming that's coming out
of it such as bending to the B so you
know like that you know there's things
that I you know that that's the one
thing that I'm really proud of it is
just keep creating and don't let
anything stop us the thing I'm not proud
of you know you know I mean I mean
there's maybe a lot of little things but
there's not a like a major thing that
sticks out you know I think everything's
always worked out you know moving from
LA to San Francisco and back to LA
worked out helped save the company and
helped me meet my fiancee you know like
you know so I can't say I would have
like been at the plate you know that the
same type of place and time I was you
know to meet her if I didn't leave and
come back so there's I mean there's
nothing no mistakes I mean the one
advice I have to give to anybody
listening is you know always save your
money you know I mean like if you want
to experiment something experiment small
don't go huge because if you save your
money have money in your bank account
you could do the first thing I was just
not talking about is you're gonna
experiment anything you want
you know so you know we were lucky we
raise a lot of money for the app we
saved a lot of it to be able to make
this pivot we didn't have to bankrupt
the company and start another company
you know I mean like it was confusing
some investors who invested into the app
but at the end they we did a service to
everybody every investor they came along
with the journey you know but we did
that because we were very always very
careful with how much we spent no matter
what it was and you guys know and those
who know listening you know how
expensive rent and developers in San
Francisco can be and we
always you know we didn't go and get the
biggest place we always treated it as if
we were running on seat C drom money and
I think that's the one thing that I have
to say that you know mistakes that I've
almost made but I didn't make it's like
blowing through money I mean I'm being
you
you know if you don't blow through money
you can save and evolve in experiment
you know I said that you know I
mentioned R&D earlier you know we have
an R&D division but it's not an R&D
division I gets four million dollars a
year to build whatever it wants you know
it's it's like hey build this you have a
$1,500 budget you know I know what I
said sounds like it's gonna cost 20
grand and I wanted to look like it cost
50 grand so you have 1500 bucks to
experiment that you know I mean that's
what that's the one a bit of advice I
have to give any content creator or
anyone who's getting into the production
business if you know people blow through
cash a lot you hear about companies
raising a billion and you know filing
for bankruptcy years later you know you
have to do that you know I mean like you
know it's like it's like sometimes the
cheaper the better you know so you know
so you know you don't have to spend a
lot of money to create content on the
internet so don't do it
I love it that's great advice to
questions to finish up and then you're
gonna get to ask me one the first one is
more serious which is what is the most
important book that you've ever read mmm
most important book I've ever read you
know I try not to read too many business
books so I don't can't really say I
recommend a book that is relevant to
everything we just talked about this
past hour I think the most important
book I've ever read has to be the
Autobiography of Malcolm X it really but
I read it early I read it when I was I
think 15 years old and to me like it it
taught me a lesson at 15 - don't feel
sorry for myself you know like the world
is gonna be very the world could be very
cruel hopefully not at school
me as it has been to other people but if
it is just keep keep your head up and
keep going and that's the one thing I
remember just always feeling and even if
I felt bullied or you know felt down and
I just felt made to be inadequate
growing up that song that that book
always gave me encouraged I recommend a
book and then I recommend the movie with
Spike Lee and Denzel Washington after I
don't recommend that or watching it
before you're that maybe you can't but I
watched the movie after and it just kind
of I visualized everything I had this
read that but the book it's just
something else that I tried to actually
advise a lot of friends and they it's a
mouth guard
as I go you didn't even tell me what to
read the Steve Jobs autobiography is
like now or biography like no no you can
read that too I'm sure that's good but
read the Autobiography of Malcolm X love
that answer
you're the first person to recommend
that one so that's a it's a great
recommendation trait I hope I hope
please you punk
anyone I'm listening please let me know
after you read it let me know if it was
right wrong and a long time since I've
read it so let remind me of some of your
favorite parts yeah for sure last
question is more fun which is aliens
believer or non-believer um yeah you
asked somebody else this in a podcast
it's a question you always ask right
yeah yeah I remember hearing and I
remember sternness think about it and
then I got freaked out which means I've
got to be a believer
I don't know much I probably don't know
I'm much more than almost anybody here
except for a it was a present that God
forgot what President I think was the
president before Kennedy had a like
there's like as article like online but
he had a meeting with the aliens out in
like the desert in California yet
there's a there's like one of the US
presidents had a me and was like no
legitimacy I don't remember which side
but it was I wasn't like you know aliens
one two three dotnet like it was like a
legitimate like publication that
actually like written it like one of the
newspapers back then ran an article
that's own so
had a meeting so you know I think
they're there
I personally you know maybe this is like
just how I feel in general life is I
think they're harmless you know I don't
think they're gonna come here and suck
the soul out of us and throw us back or
you know yeah I don't think it's like
that I think they're gonna you know I
don't know well actually maybe they're
not though maybe they do do that because
I feel like we would do that to them if
we landed on one of their planets so you
know you know I know they're there you
know are they kind of come after me I
don't know but I do think I do think
there's definitely like it's very
egotistical thing to say there is not
any other life but us you know I think
there's got to be life out there now I
don't think it's how you know these
Hollywood movies over the last few
decades have kind of portrayed them
because they have no idea yeah I tend to
agree with you right its salinity just
like we didn't get flying cars yeah I
mean just like they're just like they're
right about flying cars and mm supposed
to be now isn't it
you know like you know yeah I don't
think they're right but instead we
gather what is Tesla they've got the
like crazy mode or whatever you press
the button and oh yeah disco yeah and I
think also just goes like incredibly
fast or whatever right yeah they got a
button I think in one version of the car
where you basically press it they just
you know takes off and so we get flying
cars but we got discos and I see a disco
mode one disco my one of the creators we
work with she has a Tesla and like she
hits a button and it starts by doing
some things I don't know it's you know I
think Elon was I think on something you
know like when he's designing those
things but god bless him in his brain
he's one of my favorite people in the
poor world like I've actually because of
Sherman actually have had the expense of
time with them and the dude is just you
know is what you see is what you get
with him and yeah I think yeah they've
seized an incredible person and I think
when it comes to innovation I believe
he's just getting started you know I
think this is all day one for Elon Musk
love
you get asked me one question to wrap up
what one question you have let's see
what um I'm gonna ask that to basic
where do you see pie actually I'm gonna
ask this but more for me and even
listeners cuz I talk about podcast so
much where do you see podcast going I Y
you know where do you see it and you
know I'm kind of maybe a second question
but relevant to the first question is
and why has it been so explosive in the
last couple of years yeah so I don't
know for sure right obviously just my
personal opinion the two things I would
say is I think podcast I forget who said
this to me and just it just stuck in my
head when they said it but the idea that
right now you have air pods of your ear
and you hear someone's voice in your ear
that's a very intimate experience right
you're just hearing them it's just so
close and kind of intrusive in some way
but you're inviting it in I think that
is a really big piece of it's a very
different medium than watching somebody
or you know consuming an Instagram post
or whatever for whatever reason it's
just like podcast audio only in your ear
very intimate experience so I think that
is one piece of it the second piece is
it's very repeatable and it's very kind
of action-oriented meaning that I can
open up Instagram and I'm kind of at the
wheel of Instagram so the feed may give
me your content it may give me somebody
else's and they give me whoever else's
now they're trying to predict what I
want right so there's an element of like
they're trying to give me that but for a
podcast I actually have to click and say
play right and so that action of like
I'm constantly coming back and I'm
listening to Jon's podcast and I'm
actively clicking in and playing it it
builds this habitual thing where like
again to your point like people will
become fans right they they literally
that they're there because they want to
be there it's not something where they
just are kind of mindlessly scrolling
and it counts as a view or whatever and
so I think that naturally people pay
more
the things that they actively have to
engage in and so when you think of it
from that standpoint it feels like a a
medium where if you can build the
repeatability right and kind of the
retention of people listening over and
over and over again that relationship
between the creator and the audience is
goes much deeper than let's say somebody
falls me on Instagram right so if you
said to me like hey pick a platformer
where somebody is a follower subscriber
I would say either Twitter or podcast
not Twitter for me is just cuz I create
so much content there or the podcast is
like if I can get somebody to listen to
a podcast every day or multiple times a
week like that is such a strong
relationship with that person they're
gonna understand you know everything
that I talk about they're gonna say
anything the guests talk about right
they're gonna learn a lot but like it's
such a deep relationship that I think
people probably don't listen to like
hundreds of podcast right they probably
have you know ten or less and so you
just go much deeper on that medium with
those ten people versus you know at this
point Instagram tik-tok YouTube wherever
they people subscribe because the
platform has been around for so long
it's so many different people then it's
much harder I think to build that like
deep relationship with with the audience
yeah and I think Sam really may be the
only way to do it unless you actually do
a thing where hey you could come and sit
down with me you know one-on-one you
know but you know hi how you gonna scale
all that now those are both very helpful
and you're right you're right about that
air pods in your ear and you know and
now you can find um almost anywhere it's
just crazy to me and I think about this
all the time and I would think about
this sometimes when I'm on calls as
Spotify is how did Apple not just own
this like how did they let this go you
know like here's the thing so I keep
hearing this right and I hear from
creators I hear from like management
companies I even hear it from other like
podcasts like service companies whether
they do hosting or whatever but every
single
I talk to 50% of downloads come from
Apple and it feels like you know I think
to your point like they're not even
trying right like they're they're not
going out in acquiring bunch of content
they're not doing a bunch of things
Spotify has made a massive push you know
it's a priority at the company that
they're built the team and like and
they're really going after it but every
creator I talk to 50% of downloads come
from Apple and I think I think it's
really just they're on the iPhone
devices most likely you know for me I
think 50 60 % of the audience is in the
US right so you only get 40 to 50%
outside the US the iPhone market share
penetration in the US is off the charts
right and then Android kind of
internationally you know really makes up
for it and so when you think of it that
way it's like it's very weird that they
haven't tried or at least they it
appears they haven't tried but they
still 50% compared to everyone else yeah
yeah there's still 50% but those numbers
gonna change as the audience gets
younger right like now you're seeing a
lot of content creators launching the
podcast you're gonna see a lot of
tick-tock creators launch podcasts and
that audience is that's gonna be a
younger audience which is always almost
has been Android I mean was it was
almost all in andra at one point and now
they hand-me-down phones you know are
becoming older iPhones but it's still
Android and as the audience gets
international into markets like you know
say you get down to Brazil Mexico
Indonesia you know these are all top
markets I mean Indonesian that really
caught market for Spotify was a top
market for you YouTube and and in others
but you know these these market you know
as you these audiences start growing you
know [ __ ] has become a thing in
non-apple penetrated markets you know
they're really gonna lose a lot more
market share you know I could tell you
right now like Apple music consumption
for songs in Brazil is something you
know it's like less than 10% I even
think I don't know I know it's
definitely does like 10% I ain't think
it's maybe even one or two percent you
know and you know but a music is a
little bit different because
you know someone in Brazil who you know
which most of their population speaks
Portuguese will still listen to a song
by you know a non Brazilian artist I'd
they might not listen to an hour podcast
so but still like there's still like
market share you know I mean Brazilians
when Brazil gets into podcasting because
I mean they have already like I know
spot if I had like a some road chill
down there and some like 600 different
creators showed up at the Spotify one so
but once podcast really blow up in
Brazil whether it's in Portuguese or
English Apple's gonna have none of that
market [ __ ] zero yeah I mean like if
musics only a couple percent
what's podcast you know I'm gonna be so
and Spotify is just going to matter or
you YouTube can ever you know there you
know I mean everyone uploads clips onto
YouTube but are almost every one of
those clips on YouTube with YouTube
actually you know gets into that has a
podcast division vertical team you know
they'll be on Spotify or YouTube and it
just blows my mind that Apple would but
you're like I don't care about podcasts
I mean we're selling millions of these
devices at thousands of dollars like
shut up about free podcasts yeah dollars
a cash or whatever it is right that's
what I mean I'm a device okay yeah well
bye everybody
oh yeah I mean we're yeah yeah exactly
well five spot if I will buy you know I
mean they can't buy any Google products
but they could buy Spotify they could
buy almost anyone else it's not a you
know top tech company so our top five
type of company but um yeah maybe that's
what it is you know and I always think
to myself like human music like how are
they not so much more bigger but I'm not
you know or even a lot of things even
like that the mac mail app is so bad and
I'm like I don't care go ahead and use
Gmail yeah I mean just give us the
thousand bucks for the phone okay you
shut up and just give us the thousand
bucks and three thousand a house with a
laptop and that's it somehow everything
keeps getting more expensive right
remember when the iPhone was you know
600 bucks or 700 bucks right now is in
thousand I remember computers right
there keep seem to get more and more
expensive so yeah
something but there's something Apple
did drop the ball on not actually Alex I
think Alex talks about it with you on
your own of your previous podcast
episodes is I'm I'm in home hard work
yeah like how did they let that one slip
cuz it's too late at this point I mean
yeah I'm a Google guy still I use all
nest products but you know between
Google and Amazon you know like you know
maybe Facebook portal maybe but you know
between Google on Amazon like how are
you even gonna come close to competing
with that so I think like that I don't
know I think you know I won't see that
changing you know yet maybe don't care
that's why go ahead use the the door
bill for 200 bucks just by our phone you
know it's not fifteen hundred dollars
it's not two thousand it's now three
thousand yeah so it's gonna be
interesting to see what they do because
they got the big push into services now
and you know they're doing pretty well
but I definitely agree that there's
areas where you I you know this would
have thought they went and didn't so
yeah alright John listen I really pushed
all the time to do this is fantastic I
think yeah yeah I would love to anytime